papapapa lui
alors mon gars qui m'achètent bien les
palais
ce qui fait un tabac
travail ou
[Musique]
bâtiment
que les ossements
comme ça vous y allez un jour
regardez
vous
[Musique]
la foule a tué byrs
le coach est débile
moi j'étais db
[Musique]
et
mais je vends des trucs du ballon sans
lui je vais vous dire à nous de trouver
lui même a minima mais françois lanaud
nos maisons mais je me sens mal alors
s'étaient téléphoné alors c'est pas la
crise et de partir cheb mami et merci
vous êtes vous allé plus loin
monsieur je fais téléphoné à demande
madame je l'avais col de romme c'est
tout est ce que vous les machines et
quand les mamans ne veulent pas voulu
acheter
elle devint qui vous partiez c'est un
monsieur si vous voulez je téléphone
voyez pas que j'ai besoin de donner je
voulais pas m'acheter quelques quelques
trucs talons pourquoi un pour les mômes
que c'est la fête des mères tiens les
petites claques
voulais pas me jeter quelques vers
boston
je les difficultés à me remettre en
train de circuler c'est un cas
absolument mtg vulgaire d'aller prendre
tout ce qu elle s était de marly cher
alors prenez vos albums et quelques
loges avec lui en donne quelques noms
genève est là c'est tout on demande pas
ce que vous aviez qu'elle comptait aller
juste quelques à la dure
allez vous partez plus loin il ya encore
une école juste sorti de la mâchoire
key a bien respecté crs thierry serrés
secondes
pourquoi est ce important lors et
jusqu'à un prochain débat prétoire où
elle foulera pas les parts et la gp
comme ça si on passe toutes les vitrines
après les gens comme si l'on peut
acheter des choses et puis si on s'y
engage tous après tout le régime avait
caché puis après ça m'évitera mais est
ce que tu as déjà cassé quelque chose
toi web 2 0 et des bonnes raisons qu'on
a ce quelque chose c'est bon ça c'est
pour ça que je veux faire avec 10 avec
des
les serpentins veston et ben moi j'avais
que c'était je sais que c'était pareil à
chirac sous toujours s en plaint aussi
pourquoi pas de susciter réparer son
royaume et son armée mairie si les
prothèses les sauteries sont formés et
pas fier puisque hossa et ben oui c'est
des fusils non mais vous savez aussi bas
que les fusils non mais ça tu portes
[Musique]
après
dans une école de saint mandé nu classe
entière est parti étudier la campagne
pendant trois semaines pour beaucoup
d'entre eux c'était la première fois
qu'ils se séparaient aussi longtemps de
leurs parents le prétexte nous parut bon
nous avons bavardé avec eux le lendemain
de leur retour avec comme arrière pensée
celle de poursuivre la conversation avec
ce qu'ils parleraient le plus volontiers
visite
et puis faisait trop souvent les villes
qu'en faisait des visites étaient plutôt
des jours où il faisait très chaud et
comme levier avancer vite ça nous
fatigue et à acheter et puis on veut nos
fallait encore mme ferron celui alors
comment on était fatigué la plupart
parce qu'on nous avait forcé à marcher à
séville et puis qui faisait chaud l'on
pouvait plus et en plus de ça nous
faisait près c'est à ce changement
n'était pas vraiment d'accord 2
aller en promenade les joueuses et assez
chaud quand il faisait frais ça aurait
été un petit peu plus agréable parce que
faisait trop chaud mais oui mais aussi
vous pouvez pas savoir comme quand il
fait chaud il faisait pas chaud reçu
plus grand bien des biscuits de même
vient saper française et fils est un
garçon qui vient d'éducation populaire
sac les chats et chiens qui gardaient
cette septième bernard et puis de cette
pièce
[Musique]
madjer moi j'aurais n'est investi une
semaine de plus s'amuse bien et
département du pas non maintenant la
virilité bouteflika ni le parent aurait
dit que c'était trop dangereux parce que
des fois non ce bien la chose et puis
c'était très faim qu à la fin il se
raidit le ty pas tant que ça parce que
c'est trop pas tu te crever un abcès ou
libérale et auditrices a dit déjà une
fois c'est pour ça que tu veux quand il
n'y a pas de comité a validé son sens on
salue de villecourt alléger la pression
c'est décidé non mais moi je dis pas
parce que les femmes se seraient dit il
il se serait dit il s'est fait chez nous
ici il a l'air de trouver ça passera
bien et système u en clair les enfants
cachent difficilement leurs sentiments
dans nos conversations avec eux nous
avons cherché est attentif à une réalité
plus secrètes et plus profondes
s'ils ne se livrent pas toujours
volontiers leurs silences leurs regards
leurs attitudes sont parfois bien
révélateur pour l'autre jour à l'école
tu as dit que tu avais toi et tes
camarades l'impression d'être plus en
liberté en place verte par exemple
qu'avec les maîtres ou avec les parents
est ce que tu peux m'expliquer ça un
petit peu
[Musique]
c'est parce que tu sens pas la présence
des parents ça tu avais l'impression
d'être plus libre
d'un consensus actuel ça c'est parce que
tu ses possibilités et finalement de
pouvoir sortir quand il veut sans que ta
mère te dise vaart avait les mains
tranchées à faire vous pouvez quand même
pas sortir quand on voulait en sorte et
qu'on veut mettre une terme était un
grand frère
oui quel âge il a 11 ans et ce que
j'aime tant que toi ou est ce que je
foutais moi je peux couche en général
huit ans et demi puisse coucher et c'est
pas un peu jaloux caisse coucher après
toi six mois tout en même temps que lui
et tu dis à tes parents
non pourquoi te le redis pour sa part
dit pas moi aussi je voudrais il ya plus
de raisons parce que je suis trop fan du
roi charles ix appalaches de vérifier
tout ça tu peux pas comme tu peux pas te
coucher plus tôt vous avez combien
d'enfants
car regarde sans me méfie personne qui
agit au tir l'aîné à 11 ans 9 ans j'ai
jamais eu roche 6 3 6 1 et la dernière
mois mathieu roy
qu'est ce que vous pensez représentait
pour eux l'autorité et le bien-être la
sécurité j'allais répondre mais points
gratton
[Musique]
l'autorité certainement car les enfants
12 one la sécurité et le bien-être
je pense que c'est moi moi utile
est-ce que vous espérez que vos enfants
de vos fils en tout cas pour cent plus
tard ressemble lui ce temps dans la
mesure où nous avons suivi une question
de nos parents même dû penser de cette
unité
wallemme nous espérons leur donner les
mêmes objets divers que cinéma pas là
mais non attention je veux dire la même
éducation si le même 1er mai 10e fois
les mêmes principes si l'éducation
l'améliorer avec les robes ou du joue
aussi au foot fff
enfin qu'il ne pense que le but c'est de
leur donner une énigme quelque chose qui
soit valable dans la mesure où nous
considérons que notre éducation a été un
peu péjoratif mais en faire des hommes
qu'ils soient pas complètement repliés
sur eux mais qu'ils soient un peu à
l'écart des autres qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient généreux et c'est un petit peu ce
que nous voudrions pour pour nos enfants
qui est certaine contrainte qui le
reconnaît contre 1 pour pouvoir préparer
à la vie d'adulte
oui j'ai malgré tout dire on a des
contraintes au travail dans des
contraintes partout non il est
indispensable qu'ils aient une certaine
liberté est à l'orage mais une liberté
dans un cadre comme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
qu'est ce que vous pensez représenter
pour les enfants ou pour isabelle
puisque question d'elle
je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est leur
donner un exemple de vie comment on
croit devoir l'a mené mais ensuite c'est
tout ensuite qu'est ce que vous ayez ce
qu'ils pensent des parents en principe
quand ils ont des parents qui mène une
vie normale et je pense qu'ils n'en
pense que du bien on pas pleinement au
fond d'eux mêmes
mais même en même normalement vous
aimeriez qui vous ressemble à ce qui
ressemble à vous par un an maintenant
non non moi je n'aimerais pas
particulièrement qui me ressemble
mais ça c'est des raisons très compliqué
parce que la vie est trop difficile pour
que j'ai des enfants qui puisse me
ressemble et 10 ont rayé au niveau de
l'exemple alors oui oui moi je suis
assez satisfaite de moi tu as aussi la
bête
oui j'suis exécuté si je n'étais pas
qu'est ce que ça serait tu aimerais
ressemble à ta mère
[Musique]
pas pour une chose mais pour votre wii
et céder explique un petit peu pour la
coiffure non voilà vous hitler et la
coiffure non ce qu'elle veut et cheveux
longs les autres raisons et pour vous
pourquoi oui et toi oui parce que comme
un des fois quand je vois dans la rue et
gens qui sont décrits comme le haut j'ai
tout ça j'aime pas ça moi je n'ai pas de
précautions les as tu pas physiquement
payé et c'est bien là mais autrement il
me relevant à l'avant
super
l'autre jour à l'école là là on a
beaucoup hésité avant de dire une chose
voilà dix ans presque jamais violer l
écoute ça à la télé moffat ont toujours
envie dommage je suis active en avant
parce que dumas ccc jeudi on sait
comment tout vendu pour les plantes
hélas ce n'est qu'une petite amie l on a
fait reçu 30 ou 40 où l'alors évident je
n'écrivais 30 ou 40 ans à nantes
non non mais je crois est dit que j'en
avais écrit enfin suffisamment
honnêtement je croyais que l'aveuglé
suffisament j'ai vu que j'avais la
télévision montrent un choc c'est
derrière moi j'achète et ferons ça c'est
exceptionnel parce que la télévision est
pas là elle est à la grand mère qui est
mené les garder et qu'il allait c'est
parce que nous à la forme presse
mais ce qu'elle regarde la télévision on
espère sans doute ça chez les spurs non
et si un soir pour une raison quelconque
on tenir ce soir des profits télévision
parce que t'as pas bien travaillé
l'école ou parce que t'as pas été très
gentille tu vas te coucher et c'est la
télévision et là franchement qu'est ce
que tu fais et tu sais que ses parents
n'étant pas bien entendu les douillets
vrai oui je sais pas car tout ça ou rien
et le lendemain tellier directeur garder
rien est ce qu'il ya des choses comme ça
que tu lui dis pas et il dit devant ta
mère ça il ya la maison alors qu'est ce
que c'est pour toi au long maison pour
jouer pour garder tout ça tu peux pas
que ça tu manges également au départ et
c'est parti mon chez moi je prends le
morceau face à monsieur tels accords
annoncés avec quelques chorizo parce que
sincèrement j'aimerais comme ça voilà
j'aimerais bien que ça se passe comme ce
soir et il faut manger des pâtes et tout
ça de la salade du fromage et le
dimanche qu'est ce que tu fais des fois
je vais chez ma grand mère puis de foire
du mans au sein du fonds
le méchant qu'il faut ça dépend des fois
tu es bien sorti avec des parents
oui d'accord pour aller voir si je mens
choses comme ça puis on reste planté un
quart d'heure comme ça leur thème sortir
pourquoi alors plongé au restaurant ça
j'adore et free à le voir le théâtre et
danse ainsi premier avec des gens tout
ça tu aimeras quoi beaucoup d'enfants
plus tard non pourquoi pas du tout une
fille une fille qui doit semble non
coastal que tu tombes un bon modèle
[Musique]
c'est un autre prétexte qui nous a
amenés à bavarder avec michel il allait
déménager
c'est à dire qu'il allait aussi changer
d'école changer d'habitudes et de
copains
nous sommes allés ensemble voir sa
future maison des ouvriers travaillaient
encore et quand ça se passe pour que
leurs chargements comme ça tu quittes où
tu quittes tes copains tu quittes les
gens que tu vois et puis
je croise pas facile tu comptes des
parrains façon générale c'est à ce qui
est important présentant non geeks et ça
pas du tout ne savent pas toujours pas
ce que je vois pas toujours
et c'est comme ça pour
les parents pour les adultes en général
[Musique]
et les maîtres de mettre non plus ne se
rendent pas compte de ce qui est
important pour seb appareils c'est ce
qu'on s'est pas du tout parlé avant que
je ne parte et déjà commenceront fait
pas beaucoup et notamment aux caisses
qui représente pour toi tes parents la
tendresse la sécurité comme ça comme ça
des fois
ça va barder fois
le temps
l'autorité avait
sa notoriété c'est sûr
mais l'autorité sauf tous tu souffres de
l'autorité de départ en syrie enfin ils
sont fortement sur les terres
cependant j'ai l'impression que tu as
signé via sa cellule c'est pour ça que
mes mains très bien pour moi et pour les
autres c'est rafa mais bon révélé
peut-être normal cette autorité ou à
gauche j'espère je suis pas sûr que les
parents soient autoritaire et 1 200
chats et un an des fois tu es autorités
par an non qu'est-ce qui se passerait
esaïe jamais de leur dire moyens de
faire ça je sais
un petit peu qu'ils pensent du poivre
raison contre eux moi j'entends est-ce
que bien c'est
siècle ça y est
[Musique]
mais la liberté qu'est ce que c'est des
quêtes pour tous la liberté d'un enfant
ça serait quoi alors qu'on puisse faire
ce qu'on veut sauf des fois armand et
rattrape aux bêtises moi je suis sérieux
aider l'équipe comme ça et tu penses est
capable de juger le niveau que tes
bêtises c'est pas pour que tes parents
sont plus aptes à tapas un souvenir
quelconque qui pourrait préciser ça sur
le fait que tu te rends les doigts wii
passe il ya la peur ne sais pas j'ai
paniqué
tu sais pas où ça devienne de médias
photo pascal bats toi tu sais qu'après
de la conversation que l'autre jour on
m'a dit que tout s est sentie très très
bien ah oui ah oui ça comme si tu étais
des choses pour la première fois où l'on
passait pas à pas leur foi justement
mais j'arrive pas de sortir une fois je
vais arriver mais c'est pratique avec
tes copains en classe par exemple n'est
pas voulu s'arrêter par un peu hein mais
leur planeur non contre et un nombre
assez peu les orientales papa s'appelle
en réalité tu dit il doit pas devenir
est-ce que tu poèmes définir ce que
c'est qu'une envie c'est quoi d'abord
pour toi
c'est un bonhomme qui commandent des
enfants ce que c'est ça va nous manquer
comment des enfants
oui c'est tout ce que c'est il a peut
être d'autres sociaux c'est peut-être
des aiguilles de les élever
il ya d autres manières de les élever
non quand même à la place de leader fait
ça fais ci fais ça
alors quelles seraient les autres
manières toi tu penses avoir les enfants
plus tard ah oui alors les autres
manières et les années mais ça serait
quoi
[Musique]
bah
c'est pas bon pour le banc
tu m'as dit que tu noté des choses
qu'avant tu m'as dit que tu ne t'es des
choses des choses mais sur les carnets
ces gens voient les parents montre
remporté par an surtout par son élève et
d'ailleurs mais si tu me montres à tes
parents par exemple oui voyez vous j'ai
noté les choses parce que ça me paraît
important peut-être mais je veux pas
trop importante
paradis en congé quand j'ai été d'accord
je construise foot avec mes parents est
là je la revois aux chances un truc
comme ça au tac comme sa voix quand j'en
sais quoi aux gens sur qui occasionna
enfin jouer des trucs comme ça sans
phrases
quinton nuit tranquille autres sont des
têtes de chapitre 20 pages l'enquêté
mani d'endurance et bien par thème
qu'est ce qui a permis pour ce qu'est ce
qui va augmenter ses parts qui font jour
ce contrat qui et pourquoi
pourquoi oui donc le jour de marquer
margency s'est passé un truc important
aux graves non non non la vengeance
comme ça pour une breloque ses gosses
enfin c'était pratiquement il ya passé
sur les différentes au maroc et en art
ça dépend le jeu mais il a joué des deux
corées
adrien devrait 2-3 des contraintes et
cetera mais des degrés et u10 était
pertinent rien passé donc peut-être pour
tes parents effectivement et s'était
rien passé quelque chose de très
important
il ya encore des toits plus important ce
cas serait par exemple cgc si les
prétend que je fais une bêtise alors que
j'ai replongé rien fait à part cela je
marque vengeance 4 maximum ça dépasse
jamais cadre ce n'est pas pour le moment
c'est déjà pas mal et c'est pour lui de
marquer d'argent sur un carnet où
d'autres choses puisque tu peux pas
soutenir et 1h10 bon bah on va essayer
de discuter je voudrais vous aimez il
faudrait peut dire que je suis pas
d'accord avec telle chose là bas je sais
pourtant juste un mot est il dit dans ta
film discute et on s'étonne de la voix
c'est ce que je sois moi c'est ce que je
lui dise passe à eux quand je leur dise
a battu nice mais non c'est pas vrai du
tout bas je le ressens
il mange comment pas encore je peux pas
encore
justement je la ferai pas vu grand pour
ça je transfère attaque hors jeu quand
j'aurai fait pas beau saison est-ce que
c'est laid c'est la limite déjà si bien
16 ans c'est quoi c'est préférable
non répond pascal ceaux où il a si
l'adulte ici il ya au fond des eaux du
lac il leur faut à tout prix moi j'ai
beaucoup lu tu crois qu'on tient pas là
doute progressivement ou parce qu'à une
coupure de coupure quel couple que tu es
situe vers 16 ans non la coupure c'est
plutôt d'un 18 à 18 ans quand tu veux
avec 18 ans dans la rue tu étais ducasse
tu te dis que c est foutu mais tu
parlais tout à l'heure de coupure entre
le la gigue en tout cas entre les
enfants et les adultes et un jour porte
basculer deux côtés il y aura une
coupure organes coupure à toutes les
choses que tu as appris en décadence et
qui remettront en question à nos alliés
les choses que j'aurais après il reste
au bout non ça va ça fera comme un c'est
comme si on retourne dans un précipice
auraient ils vont au fond mais alors on
a tout ce qui nous reste dans le crâne
souviens parce qu'il y aura au oui oui
c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait pareil
dans quelle mesure tu crois qu'un adulte
peut intervenir
la vie d'un enfant trop quelle mesure il
peut pas intervenir parce qu'il doit
intervenir et toi oui mais gary feront
un geste argentine
[Musique]